hey everybody and welcome to a
truly special wild ride with stevo
this week we've got a legend man there's
no other way to put it
a legend of so many things and a
personal hero of mine from way back in
the day
and dude we're both van lifers man so
let's dive into it let's look let's not
leave it in the hallway as they say
i learned i learned that saying from you
okay here
here's how we do it yeah ladies and
gentlemen
tom green
i'm not sure if you've met my co-host
scott yeah we've met
we've met at the airport you're like
look it's tg
yeah dude i was like what's up tg what's
up man how are you good to see you good
to see you yeah good to see you too
up at the front of the van we got the
gorgeous paul briskey hey tom how are
you wow that's cool so you guys are all
in the van right now
that's right that's amazing are you are
you uh
in some uh amazing place right now i'm
i'm not in my van right now i'm i'm in
my house but you've been here to my
house before
this is not the ban yeah many times
we're just parked outside of my house
dude
so much of this okay darn pandemic you
know we had such big plans for the van
we're gonna
we're gonna drive it to all these
magnificent places we're gonna bring it
to make podcasting convenient for huge
stars we've got the mobile studio
and for the most part it just sits at
the house and and we're
talking to a computer screen in here oh
really so like
the reason i got my band was because of
the pandemic because i needed to kind of
get out of the house
right but but i've been i've not really
been going to talk to anybody i've just
been going and sitting all by myself in
the middle of the desert
i know i've been uh i've been enjoying
your youtube channel
um yeah thanks man thank you it's been
kind of like
all right fairly we're not the best yeah
i've been kind of like just sort of on a
little photo
photography videography kind of journey
you know
right it's been it's been very peaceful
and relaxing
and uh how long have you been back at
home at your house
uh just i've been home for a couple of
days but then i i kind of go back and
forth like i go
go out for a couple of weeks and then i
come back and uh
you know take a shower yeah
yeah i know i just saw in your your most
recent youtube video you were talking
about
it sounded like bathing and showering
exclusively
in lakes and rivers uh
yeah well it's gotten too cold for that
now that's the problem so now it's just
no bathing whatsoever but it's fine you
know i'm by myself
i don't mind the way i smell you know i
smell all right to myself i wouldn't
want to be with anyone and like smell
like the way i smell but like when i'm
by myself i don't mind you know
yeah gotta say you look great dude i
haven't had a haircut in a year you know
i think i might have to go back to the
old school uh you know skater look
right i mean dude yeah i think you look
great you just texted me a photo of you
and tony hawk and you called it skinny
tom
which made me think that you got fat or
something but
you're not feeling it off i think i did
get fat
but then i lost some weight again during
the pandemic so i'm i think i've
i'm almost skinny tom again yeah yeah
dude
and that did so much to talk about like
the
the history that that we have there's so
many things that
did he get bored of being called the the
father of podcasting
remember remember how much how much
crazy [ __ ] we did up here in this in
this room back in the day
when we were streaming back in like 2003
oh my god do i remember
yeah let's hear about it to come up here
every time you came up
that's when we really got to know each
other when i started the the webo vision
up here
and uh you would come up and you'd
always come bring some crazy
stunt or something i remember you know
you brought a microwave up and we were
burning a bunch of [ __ ] in the microwave
there was probably some other stuff that
i don't need to bring up but you know it
was a lot of fun was had up here that's
for sure there was a lot of
skateboarding in your living room there
was a lot of consumption of
alcohol and me with my with my whippets
there was a lot of us rapping together
you rapping really well and me rapping
terribly and uh
there's just a lot of crazy times man it
was and you've always been such a
such a good friend to me you know like
supportive
and and uh you know caring when things
were bad and
you know like forgiving when uh
like when i didn't deserve forgiveness
you know you've always been a really
great
guy tom man yeah man well you too you
too i mean
you know i think like you know when when
we were younger that was quite a while
ago now that was probably how many years
ago was that 2003
he quit math almost 20 years ago right
you know
i mean i was drinking a lot then too you
know and uh
and so we come up here you come up here
we do the show we
i remember one show went five hours
drinking and uh you know i uh
you know i've cut back quite a bit on
the on the booze myself steve oh i i
haven't
entirely quit but uh i'm glad to see
you're doing so good and you're so
healthy now and everything it's
it's actually inspiring i'm thinking
maybe i have to
take a page out of the stevo uh book to
health and happiness and uh
give it up entirely oh well you know
thank you for the kind words i think
that
it's uh you know if it's if it's not
uh screwing up your life then then
you know who cares man you know i i
think in general
you're you're a a pretty happy guy
you know i think of you as a guy who's
not like too caught up in all the
the rat race and the stress of life
i wish that i i have my ups and downs
for sure you know i
i think i got a pretty good balance
going on but uh
you know i mean i definitely had had had
low moments in
in in life and and where i've definitely
been down and uh
i think i've i think i've learned
actually a lot in the last
10 years or so that like you know booze
you know whether i haven't entirely quit
drinking but i have cut
back to sort of a more sensible amount
of drinking and
um and i know that when i don't drink at
all
i am much happier which is very
counterintuitive because
i always used to think oh you know you
drink and it makes you get crazy and it
makes you have fun but
but then the next day you feel like [ __ ]
and then you compound that with
getting older and that that is even more
amplified
i really found when i started doing
stand-up again like you know
that was really where it really kicked
in and i realized wow this booze isn't
really helping me out too much because
you know you'd be hungover the next day
and you're you're not sharp and you're
not like really like feeling positive so
it's interesting you know i'm starting
to hear a lot of comics and people
talking about this where people are like
not drinking and i'm thinking geez that
just sounds very
sort of different than what we sort of
grew up hearing about comedians you know
people were all
always so rock and roll and they were so
out there getting you know doing drugs
and doing i never did drugs but you know
uh
and boozing it up but now people are
getting so straight edge it's it's kind
of a nice thing i think
yeah i'll never forget never forget the
first time i i watched
you stand up tom you invited me to uh
the hollywood improv it was uh
i'm sure it was 2010 so
now uh 11 years ago and i remember like
just not being sure what to expect and
and and just being so impressed i
remember thinking dude he was on stage
for like a whole hour
and he never like forgot what he was
supposed to say or anything
you know like it was uh it's
really cool man and at that time i had
no idea that i would be uh
you know sort of following and following
your path into stand-up
now of course tom's first thing was
stand-up like way back before the
hidden camera pranks isn't that right
yeah
sure yeah i mean that's kind of in
canada there was a
there's a club called yuck yucks in
ottawa and uh it's the comedy club up in
ottawa and when i was in high school i'd
go down there and kind of discovered
stand up and
and uh loved it and some of the great
stand-ups that i still love like
like norm mcdonald for instance was from
ottawa and he was
just starting out there i remember going
to watch him
you know when i was 15 years old and it
was cool because like
it was a bar but you could still go if
you were a teenager i guess it had its
restaurant license or something like
that
so it felt such like such an adult thing
to do like you go to the bar
and watch comedy in this dark basement
and here's this guy norm mcdonald and
jeremy hotz and all these guys that came
from ottawa who were
at the time in their early 20s and just
so
crazy like doing such weird stuff sit
talking about weird
stuff and it was different than anything
you'd see on tv you know it was like
you know nor mcdonald's you know out
there right but in 1988
it was like really really hard to
imagine
like what you were even seeing you know
because everything on tv was so straight
you know
right so that was really exciting you
know and um
but it's it's it's interesting you know
now
doing stand-up now the way you and i
have been
crossing paths touring the world doing
shows together in vegas
and right you know it's like it really
is
i think just sort of uh i'm just so glad
that uh
that we both kind of are doing this now
because it's like
it really gives you a lot of control
over your life now doesn't it to be able
to just go out and
do your thing with your audience and uh
now travel around in our vans man we
really do have very similar lives
think of it right i mean you would think
that i was just spending my whole life
just
just copying tom green
i mean tom green was uh i mean
you were my hero before jackass was even
an idea
the tom green show on mtv i've said this
so many times like i literally
sat there and and recorded every episode
of the tom green show and was so
careful when the commercial break
started i would hit pause on my vcr
to in real time edit out the commercial
breaks and then hit record again when
the commercial break was over
i had the whole library of the tom green
show and i just loved it so much man i
remember
when we filmed jackass for the first
time uh
like i shared a room with our line
producer
who who told me that i was like what
other shows have you done he said i
worked on the tom green show and all of
a sudden i just had this
reverence for this this producer that
tripper
it was it was tripp trip did the tom
green show
tripp did the tom green chair and i just
thought that was so cool man
and if you think so there was the you
know the the godfather of the of the
you know podcasting wow that the
podcasting came after but
yeah what do you call that what that
mean hidden camera you can't say
the hidden camera because like candid
camera had been around for so long but
like
that man on the street gag that just
weird
you know like there's definitely and
i've always really looked up to people
who can
make footage that's that's compelling
and that's that's
awesome without like doing anything uh
you know dangerous or or destructive or
you know like or super gross and puke
everywhere like
well we got pretty gross but yeah
painting your parents house plaid or
or paying their car the [ __ ] mode yeah
yeah you know i mean it's interesting
right like
because we were both skateboarders and i
loved skateboarding as a kid
and so you know for me like when i was a
kid
i would watch like paulo peralta videos
you know like i was watching like
it was it was future primitive was the
first one that i saw
that was like where i remember seeing
video that didn't look like it was made
by you know nbc or something you know it
was like
stacy peralta's future primitive and
they were going
you know they were cruising around new
york city
and jumping off like the back of you
know vans and
lance mountain would like wipe out like
flip around on the ground and [ __ ]
and everyone was like on the street real
people reacting and i was looking at
that going like
man like that's like raw real
like energy that i've never seen on
television before
except for maybe maybe a little bit of
david letterman was doing stuff like
where he'd go in the street but
everything else was so controlled so so
uh
you know kind of uh rehearsed and
everything so
but you know we kind of grew up at that
same time where it's like
you know all of a sudden we had we could
get a video camera right like we didn't
get a video camera before
and all of a sudden you could go out and
make sort of gorilla
gonzo kind of amateur tv
which you know maybe it wasn't as
perfectly shot or perfectly
produced but the fact that it was so raw
and nobody ever like
when people looked at you when you went
up to someone on the street they didn't
think that you were from the tv station
because you weren't
and so they'd kind of react real and it
was just the right time
you know like we just sort of you know
we were both there at that time when all
of a sudden like
everything changed we started filming
stuff
no youtube nobody watching had ever seen
anything like that before and sometimes
i kind of like feel like
man like i don't think people today
young people today
i don't think they can kind of quite
grasp how crazy it was when
when our [ __ ] came on tv back in the
early
or 90s because like nobody had seen it
before now like you can put stuff like
that out now and you can do stuff like
that now but they're comparing it to all
the stuff they see we're overwhelmed by
all this weird video it doesn't have
that impact that it had back then
i'm so fat there's so much here and i'm
so fascinated by it because i think what
made it so special was that
at that time when you and i started
filming our stuff
the video camera was still not yet
really
a household item you know it was like
pretty you know not
not most households had a video camera
and it was skateboarders who were the
first to
the first to really we had such a leg up
in video production skateboarders
because our whole culture of
skateboarding was about
trying to get sponsored so you had to
videotape your skateboarding in order to
try to get sponsors
and there was never another activity
that lent itself to making
videos like say for example if you were
a tennis player then you want to get
sponsored then
when you win tournaments you know check
out my tennis video
yeah there was no other thing like there
was no other thing like
skateboarders that really like first
came to the video camera we got so far
ahead of everybody
else with the video camera and at a time
when it wasn't a household item
and you're absolutely right plus when
our stuff came out on mtv
still the average person didn't have a
video camera let alone in their pocket
and the media wasn't so fragmented to
where there was like i mean sure there
was there was cable tv and there was
network tv
but when when our stuff came out there
was no such thing as playing
videos on the internet i mean
it was like weber vision at tom in tom
green's living room was like
really the first streaming video i think
right yeah i got i've got so much
footage of us i've got it all on
drives and on tapes and stuff like i
mean
uh don't worry i'll i'll i'll i'll let
you see it before i don't
i don't i don't mind one bit tom i don't
mind one bit
and it was it was publicly it was pretty
crazy though man like i remember it was
it was like
you know that was i mean that was kind
of exciting because
you know when i was doing the web show
here in this room right like this
that's that's where we were sitting
right there you're sitting where the
bleachers were
yeah i'm right i'm right where the
bleachers were at bleachers in my living
room
and it was just like stevo would bring
his friends i'd have my friends and
people just sort of sit here and watch
and get a little studio audience you
know that's great
there was like a lot of like big time
people in there like
we had really great hours and hours in a
row with carson daly i remember that
fondly dr jews i mean there were some
some
you had a lot of uh really famous people
in there
yeah it was it was weird because like
you know it felt a little bit like you
know when i started my show
you know on public access we were kind
of doing something that
was kind of unique right because the
video camera
was sort of a you know shooting with i
didn't actually have a video camera i
had to go pop
volunteer at the public access station
so they'd lend me their video camera you
know nice
i didn't have any money i had no money
you know i was like so broke i was i
worked at dairy queen uh you know i'd
make 100 bucks a week i'd spend it all
on a new skateboard deck or
you know a drum machine or save up for
thing i'd never had any money for a
video camera video cameras were like 2
dollars or something like that you know
so uh
yeah but like and then we did the webo
vision that was like that was kind of
later you know
it's it's weird like how that seems like
a long time ago now because it doesn't
like to me that always feels like
you know it was like that was after my
show on mtv
but it was but it's now a long time ago
which is scary because that means like
we're really [ __ ] old now is that
what that means
yeah yeah we're pretty old i remember uh
we were together doing stand-up comedy
in scotland ah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah when you turned
forward it was your 40th birthday
oh [ __ ] yeah that was 10 years ago then
yeah almost yeah
yeah that was cool the edinburgh
festival did you guys have a
a lot in con your moms went to the same
high school oh that's right that's right
that like it's such a small world
yeah our moms went to the same high
school in barrie ontario is that right
yeah my my mom said to say hi i was
talking to my mom this morning and she
she she knew your mom and uh she knew my
mom
i know how did you guys find that out
dude
i'm not even sure but dude did i ever
tell you the joke
that i was so my mom told me that's how
we figured it out yeah
my mom called me up one day you know and
and uh
you know after jackass came out and uh
and she said oh you know what's so
strange
you know stevo from jackass i was
friends with his mom
isn't that a small world you know that's
how my mom talks and uh
and so yeah like uh she was like they
were friends they were like
they were good friends like they knew
each other i think your mom was one
grade below my mom but they all like
hung out and knew each other so that's
great man that's cool
that's great i'd like one so it's been
something when i'm doing
stand-up in canada i would say like you
know wow like
i'm actually canadian and and it's
completely true
that my my most prized possession is my
canadian passport
i really think because like is it going
to be a time when being
having the ability to go over into
canada is going to be something
really really of value
that could be the time right now it
might have been six months ago right
just about but i would do this when i
would say in canada you know like
but i'm canadian because my mom was born
in canada
and then i'd say my mom actually went to
high school with
tom green's mom yeah yeah i think it was
barry north collegiate i think yeah say
and then i'd say uh but my mom was a way
bigger [ __ ]
why would you say that because it's a
ridiculous thing
of course i'm kidding i think that if it
came down to it it would probably be
true but i don't know it's not my
business
[Laughter]
that's so funny you know i mean how do
you come up with that joke like oh my
parents went to school together but like
my mom's probably a [ __ ] like why would
you
like how would you make those kind of
things i don't know i mean you just
think you think of like
i think it's funny because if you
imagine tom green's mom and then you
imagine
steve o's mom okay like
stevo's mom would probably have been a
bigger [ __ ] but who knows
you know i don't know i asked my mom
about that
for uh for you tom like when jackass
first came out did you feel like oh
these are my
allies this is like a progression of
what i'm doing or did it feel like
they were sort of taking what you did
for the record as inspired by tom green
as i was
i don't think that i ever tried to copy
him
but we'll see what he says and speaking
of records
boy did i set one on my whoop app
when i went on that crazy 86.9
bicycle ride down to san clemente yep
and what's so
cool about the whoop app is that when i
kick butt like that
it's not just the woop app that knows
about it it's my bros
too because we're all in a group
together and some days you know what
i lose some days i win but we're always
motivating each other
to stay fit and healthy and get rest and
it's just awesome man such a cool thing
to be a part of and it's time for you to
try it
so this is how you do it you go to
woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com and this is how you're gonna get
set up with the most
insightful technologically advanced
fitness
tracking system there is okay so
whoop.com
you're going to use the promo code stevo
and that's going to get you 15
off at checkout and do it because you're
going to know more about what's going on
with your body than you
ever have before and so will you bros
so one last time woop.com
use the promo code stevo and see if you
can burn 4324 calories in a single day
because i did and my bros know it
yeah dude all right i remember i went to
like a screening of it
i remember seeing you there i was like
no way
but that was for the movie not the
series oh right right right
yeah i know i mean i remember it was i
think i was in new york when it first
came out and i was kind of like
yeah i thought it was amazing like it
was definitely
different i didn't think it was the same
thing because
you guys were kind of more like physical
more skateboard
oriented too like my show like because i
was a skateboarder but
i always kind of we i was trying to do
more like a david letterman type show
you know
yeah and you guys were definitely doing
more of the the physical stunts and
stuff
which i uh was sometimes kind of
i was shocked you know like uh that uh
but i don't know like dude i don't know
if we really met each other right away i
don't think
i don't think kind of walking by each
other at that screening and i was just
sort of
you know really thrilled to to see
like to be in tom green's presence with
something pretty special for me
and it's a weird thing because it's like
i had only been really living in
you know the united states for a few
years at that point and
i don't i i've real i've learned
something about myself over the years
which is
i i think i had like a lot of social
anxiety when i was like younger like i
got really nervous
meeting people and stuff so i didn't
really ever know like what to say
like when i was around like you guys or
you know
you know like when we were talking about
tony hawk you know like how you get to
skate with tony hawk now and
someone just sent me some pictures of me
and tony skating back in 1999 and
i posted them on my instagram today but
it took me back to those years where i
was like
you know i was just sort of overwhelmed
and intimidated by people you know so i
was always i think it was sometimes like
i was kind of like
you know people misunderstood it as like
oh is this guy like not want to talk to
me but really i was just kind of
scared shitless like whenever i would
run into somebody that i kind of was
amazed by
you know and i just sort of sit there in
silence you know but um
i don't did you find that or were you
just not not like
not i don't think that it was really a
situation
where we were introduced or had a big
conversation so
i i i didn't have any uh you know like
i didn't find you standoffish or
anything i just found you standing over
there
ish yeah yeah it wasn't really we didn't
really kind of get to know each other
probably until we did the web show like
five years later you know right
yeah yeah did you like um i kind of like
worry about you guys a lot like not so
much now but like
because like
like you guys like actually really get
hurt
like right badly right like like i i
never really did the jumping off
things or right you know and so i kind
of like
i'm somewhat amazed that like um
that you guys are able to do some of
that stuff and not actually permanently
get hurt like
doesn't johnny knoxville actually really
kind of hurt himself pretty badly right
uh a number of times and i think that uh
it would be good for him to be very
careful
with his brain from this point forward i
think that yeah like concussions and
stuff i think he's used up all of his
free concussions
so when you guys are doing stuff now
like you're doing you're doing another
movie now right we've been shooting
another movie yeah
so is it going to be like as physical
like are you going to do
as much sort of painful stuff
that's uh that's that's right tom yeah
and so and so like like uh
is there any sort of there there must be
some i'm gonna kind of interview you now
for a second but
there must be some like pressure to
one up the uh the last big stunt
and uh you know some things are kind of
maybe not one-uppable right like i mean
like are you concerned that maybe you're
gonna push it too far
you know there is that concern
and um like if if
uh if there was something you could
imagine
like not ever wanting to one-up like
that in my
mind for the particularly for knoxville
like one
thing where you think oh please don't
try to one-up that and then yeah
he totally went up to that
wow no he won and i have did
yeah specifically
yeah well just don't don't uh you know
don't um you know
overdo it be careful
yeah right maybe be careful while you're
not being careful
right i mean we're we're pretty close to
uh
having gotten away with it so i don't
want to say anything more
but then there's more there's more to do
but but the the majority of it
is in the can i probably shouldn't even
say that but i did
so far so good right and and now i'm
going to go back to
i want to this isn't even a question
it's it's a comment
but tom i gotta say i think that you're
if not the most
certainly one of the most talented
people i know you know like with
uh well i mean
it's a pioneer too and like so much
[ __ ] talent with the
the rapping and and with the comedy and
and
inventing planking
you invented planking yeah well
plankton what do you mean i didn't i
didn't call it planking but
one of the early bits on my show i would
go and i would just lie down on my face
until people came and called an
ambulance you know and then you know
years later everyone was lying down on
their face and and
i was credited with that but uh but we
didn't really call it planking but
but yeah you know i mean you know this
it's like
we we kind of like uh you know what i
find interesting about the world today
is everybody's kind of doing what we did
back when we were younger you know so
many people
like people are kind of able to go out
and kind of create their
own thing and do their own thing and and
uh that was sort of so much
sort of more of an obscure idea back in
the day where you could actually just go
make your own
your own content as they call it content
so um i mean it's uh
it's it's it's it's sort of weird to
think that uh we're still doing this
[ __ ] you know
right certainly you know i sometimes
kind of kind of find it amazing because
you know i'm turning 50 this year and uh
you know i'm trying to do different
things now but it's still kind of all
rooted in the same thing you know i'm
really enjoying the video i'm doing
enjoying doing photography
i've got you know my new cameras my
drone i'm going out there shooting all
these
rad shots you know it's your birthday in
august
what's that it's your birthday in august
july 30th
yeah it's pretty close pretty close yeah
yeah oh yeah
yeah um now here's a question that i get
really fascinated by
and and it's it's it's a question that
only applies really to us
but if you and i were born 20
years later so that when we
first started making videos there was
youtube
yeah yeah you know like would we
have uh we'd both be working at dairy
queen right now
i mean i i a little bit think you know i
think you can only really interpret that
question but for me
um i think that it would be a problem
because there is
so much content out there just anybody
can just
click of a button and put put up a video
like
it was uh there's a lot more noise to
have to rise above
in in this day and age and i think also
that with the algorithms and and this
and that
like it's about quantity of footage more
than quality of footage you know it's
like these these
vloggers the most successful youtubers
they're
successful because they're putting up
videos every single day
so it's not it's not about like i always
shot like just little tiny snippets of
something that was like super intense
but like i never had a very long
video to put out you know like i think i
would have suffered
i think that i personally benefited a
great deal by being born when i was born
yeah for sure i mean definitely timing
is important for everything and
also i think like maybe we'd just be
doing something completely different
because
it's also just about like kind of
thinking different you know so like
because everyone's doing that now maybe
we would have maybe we'd be like into
computers or something
right you know we'd probably be like you
know
cryptocurrency guys or something you
know i don't know
man i'm too much of an intention i'm
such an attention [ __ ] i i can't
imagine doing anything but
seeking attention right right yeah well
i think what's interesting like had you
guys been born
20 years later would there be a youtube
like kind of what what you guys did
and what skateboarding did and what bam
did like
led to that in in a lot of ways so
you're saying we sort of
ruined everything thank you pretty much
i mean you just
you changed the game but i mean the
amount of work you guys went through to
edit a video back then like it's just so
different now it takes you know
everybody can edit a video on their
phone but like you guys were putting in
work
i mean weren't you like recording vcrs
and
having two tvs and putting them together
and stuff like that yeah
when you guys were first filming stuff
was it the big like over-the-shoulder
camera or had cameras gotten
small and like handheld by that time
i don't know tom did you use a full-size
vhs or were you on the vhsc tip
so we had a few different cameras in the
early days so
we'd go down to the station that i
volunteered at and i also i went to
broadcasting school so we had high eight
cameras we had uh which sucked
and uh we had because you know you'd get
all the dropouts on the tape you know
uh but uh then there was an svhs camera
we shot a lot which
was pretty good it was the s s that's
better than just a straight up vhs
like svhs right um
and then and then we had you know then
minidv came along later and stuff so
yeah a few few few big cameras minidv
felt like pretty exciting you know
because it was digital
smaller compact you know uh-huh yeah i
remember making the jump from uh
high eight to digital at first yeah and
then i jumped back
now here's a question tom um i remember
you coming out with your own beer is
that something that people can still buy
yeah it's it's it's only in canada there
right but yes you can get it it's called
the tom green beer
you can't buy it online in america and
have it shipped to america
i i don't think they're allowed to ship
it across the border but uh it might
it might be available in new york state
it was for a while but it's really i
might have to go take a trip to canada
when they open the border up to drink my
beer
but uh maybe one of these days i'll get
it down in the us but not here yet so
yeah now i also remember you being a pro
skateboarder for
birdhouse yeah yeah i've got
i i was tony sort of made me i'd say an
honorary member an
honorary member of the team you know
which was fun went on tour
uh remember we went on tour with bam
once uh we did a
sort of a cross-country demos where we
drove around in these lexus
cars that they gave us and uh jeremy
klein and uh
bam and tony and uh
the whole team you know brian sumner
willie santos
um you know bucky lassic was andrew
reynolds i don't think he was no he
wasn't on birdhouse then this was sort
of after i think he
left done another thing but uh but that
was that was kind of like to me was sort
of like
sort of a uh a dream
a dream come true in a way where i
couldn't even really believe that i had
like my own
you know pro model board you know and it
was
and jeremy klein you know did all the
graphics
you know uh actually and uh sean cliver
actually drew it yeah
so sean cliver jackass uh uh family
drew my graphic and then jeremy klein
kind of designed it
and so it was like a real skate graphic
you know like it really was the old
school
type design graphic so that was pretty
sweet you know i mean i
i was obviously like kind of like i had
a few tricks i like to do
i was definitely love skateboarding like
i have a love for skateboarding
when i was a kid like you know in ottawa
you know i wasn't even really like there
was a lot of skaters in ottawa that were
pretty good i was pretty good but
you know i mean i wasn't really like uh
like like
you know doing the kind of stuff that
you're you can do and you know i could
do some things i could do like i i like
to power slide a lot
yeah bonelesses i like to do like i used
to i used to be
i used to have a nice launch ramp at my
house when i was a kid
and i i i used to be able to do like 360
errors
early grab three strips 60 errors but i
never really got it on video
which is kind of like something that i'm
because we didn't have a video camera
and i probably really only landed one
super clean like maybe like
five times you know and that to me
probably is like my biggest regret in my
life
that opening sequence of freddie got
fingered
it was a skateboarding sequence we were
going through the mall and the opening
sequence and it was
really well shot it was super super
badass man
so that was kind of like so for me like
the first time i ever saw skateboarding
in a real movie
was when back to the future came out
yeah that was when i started
that's why i wanted to put this opening
scene i wanted to have skating and
freddie got finger because now i got
opportunity to make a movie and
i wanted the opening scene to be me like
me skating somewhere and going somewhere
what i loved about back to the future
was like
like how that shaped my life was weird
because
you know that was like i was i loved
skateboarding and i had a skateboard but
i didn't
they didn't have like the big boards yet
you know they were it was the banana
boards right right
and then back to the future came out and
it was like a different kind of board
you know it's like it was when that sort
of the 80s start and the
fluorescent sort of splatter paint and
the big
wheels and the in the and and i saw that
board i thought what what is that board
that is a crazy looking board and then
all of a sudden those boards started
coming up
and and it was like the fact that he
would escape to school
and getting onto the truck was so cool
yeah and he had a backpack on
and huey lewis and the news was
and so like for some reason like when i
was in like the ninth grade i thought
like
i gotta listen to huey lewis and the
news right because like
that's like power of love important
music you know yeah so i'd like
i put on my sony walkman i'd pop in my
huey lewis in the news sports cassette
and i'd listen to the heart of rock and
roll
and i'd replicate the the michael j
fox skateboarding the school scene every
day going to school
for my entire high school career
and it always felt like the coolest
thing because like back then like
skateboarding wasn't cool like when i
was in high school like i was like one
of maybe two guys in my school that
actually
skateboarded and all the other kids in
school were kind of like
you know we're trying to be cool now
right we're
we're we're listening to the eagles and
we're wearing like you know penny
loafers and we're wearing like you know
polo
and i'd be showing up with like skulls
on my pants
and my hair was like you know like crazy
down to here
that way and and and if i skateboard and
people would kind of look at you like
why are you on a skateboard man you're
in high school you're an adult now what
are you an idiot
right yes
skateboarding wasn't cool when we were
kids man
yeah yeah so so now let's talk about
your rapping because i've always been so
impressed by
by tg the rapper wow yeah you guys are
both rappers
we're both rappers we're both skaters
we're both
podcasters we're both van lifers
we're both pranksters
mtv yeah man crazy it's it's mtv alumni
it really is crazy um yeah i mean todd
what was first the the um
was it the stand up or the bra
with the public access is what i'm
looking for the the tv
public access was kind of first i'm just
going to let
charlie outside wants to go for a potty
uh the wrapping was kind of before the
public access yeah
i was like um i was like uh
here by the way this is where the this
is where the studio used to be
this is where we would sit that is
exactly
um but uh the uh
the rapping i was like started doing
that in high school when i was like 16.
and um yeah it was kind of like
it's kind of what actually made me
realize that like technology was
what was kind of uh
the thing that you had to pay attention
to because like when rapping came out in
the 80s like
when rap music became popular in the 80s
like it was like
drum machines were new you know it was
like electronic music was new
and i remember saving up all all summer
working my
my job at dairy queen so i could buy
this used yamaha drum machine
when i was like 17 or 16 years old and i
i basically started making these beats
with an atari computer hooked up to this
drum machine
and we go down my high school and we do
these like we play at the christmas
concert
and my buddy greg who was in the group
who called organize rhyme or videos on
youtube
and we we started like doing these songs
and then we started opening up for all
the punk bands when they come to
come to ottawa you know we hooked up
with the promoter and we were the only
rap group in ottawa
so we'd go down and open for these punk
bands these canadian punk bands dude
no like we would open for like a lot of
local bands that were from ottawa you
know and
you know i'm trying to think of you know
like snfu
we never actually opened for them no i i
think we might have seen them but it was
more like there was this there's
what groups were we open for we were
open for like these canadian groups and
uh
i'm trying to think of the name of the
the bands we opened for a lot of local
stuff
and uh you know like they were like
local bands like the illegal jazz poets
and uh we opened for the bare naked
ladies ones not a punk band but uh
um boot sauce was this canadian rock
band we opened for a bunch of times
and uh which is hilarious by the way
check that out but um
but then we sort of started doing that
and we got a record deal and that was
kind of like
wow you know like we actually got a
record deal after doing this for about
four years and
and uh and it was kind of it was kind of
neat you know it's kind of neat that we
were able to pull that off
how many rappers were there in the group
one other one yeah greg greg greg
campbell this other guy and
nice yeah so yeah like when we were like
when we were teenagers we went down to
new york city and we recorded a demo
we had someone bring us down there to
record a demo and i remember thinking
at that early age like sort of putting
it all together like oh you know like
you work hard with like
you know you get a drum machine and you
you
make some songs and then you can maybe
try to like
get into show business or something like
that you know
that's paul's catchphrase is make stuff
till you make it
make [ __ ] till you make it yeah yeah and
it all just was that just doing it
ourselves kind of thing you know which
was kind of it was kind of exciting you
know
so how about what are you doing look at
charlie what are you doing charlie
what are you doing this is the best dog
by the way it's like i mean
i mean i know you got the best dog too
but this dog is so funny
yeah you're charlie you're crazy she's
like a really good dog
she's a rescue from look at this look at
this thing
i like charlie hello charlie she just
perked up charlie
look at you look at you hello charlie hi
hi hi hi hi
hi hi hi hi hi hi hi
love it man so you're a prolific
freestyler too like how legit is
freestyling you just come up with
something out of nowhere
well i don't know i don't know i think i
think
i think a lot of times freestyling is is
defined in different ways like sometimes
it's not necessarily always off the top
like every word is
off the top sometimes it's some people
refer to freestyling as
total off the top but then sometimes
it's just more like wrapping over a beat
could be pre-written lyrics and stuff
like you know like when i
there's that video online where i'm
rapping with the exhibit and everyone
says i'm freestyling
it's not like those were some lyrics
that i'd written
you know there were lyrics that were in
my head memorized right
but it was over a different beat and it
was kind of throwing it down in the
you know in the moment so i i have a
hard time really freestyling freestyling
where you're totally making it up
to be honestly i kind of sometimes
question whether or not not that even
is a real thing you know i think people
have a lot of written verses a lot of
lyrics in their heads
because uh you know you want to have
some sort of payoff you want to have
some sort of a punchline
right and if you just kind of start
going off the top it might just be a
bunch of garbage coming out of your
mouth you know unless you're
i mean i've seen some that are pretty
incredible yeah i think my favorite one
is
juice world who did like four hour long
freestyle on
radio that's pretty impressive
right and i've seen other ones where the
audience will make suggestions of what
the
subject matter should right and then
they just put it together and it's like
okay well that's
looks pretty yeah i've seen a guy on
youtube doing that and it is really
really impressive yeah yeah yeah so i
look back on my rap
chapter of my life trying to become a
rapper as like
arguably the most humiliating just most
terrible
part of my life but all of these years
later all of these years later i can't
help
but feel compelled to try to redeem
myself
i i feel like i want to make a rap
redemption
track yeah yeah yeah yeah well you know
that's one of the things that like i'm
like
still love doing is making beats like
i've got a little little
drum uh drum machine and set up in my
in my van so i'll send you some beats
man and uh you know throw some [ __ ] on
that
and send it back and we'll we'll mix it
up and we'll put that [ __ ] out
dude i love it and and uh as we
we were you know just sort of
brainstorming oh what would my rap
song be about it's very interesting to
me that the one
topic that we really settled on would be
a
rap song about van life
right how about that huh that'd be good
let's do it that's that'd be great
you guys should meet out in the desert
and [ __ ] yeah i would love to go on
like a little uh
little van trip with you i think yeah
let's do it for sure man like uh we can
make some great
youtube yeah i mean i'm basically like
uh
doing this all the time now like i'm
going to start touring with my van and
i'm going to stop
you know just this whole year has
changed my whole perspective on things
like i don't really want to uh
you know take airplanes as much anymore
that's tricky dude that's tricky yeah
that's kind of what i want to do but but
i mean like uh yeah like
let's let's uh what kind of van do you
have by the way it's a
ram promaster oh okay yeah
and so like i'm trying to picture like
how you've got it set up right now
because
yeah we're in the back this is the rear
lounge and the the rear lounges
it converts into a bed area but
above me is a second bed which lowers
down from the ceiling
whoa okay so it's set up totally
differently than the way mine's set up
yeah yeah seems like you got like a lot
more space the way you're doing it i
just i kind of have like my bed
and uh you know yeah dude i got a shot i
gotta shout out the people who make this
it's uh
it's been converted by regency rv
and oh nice nice yeah that's cool yeah i
uh i got mine with this company called
boho
and they do like really cool [ __ ] too
tell me about the bad the battle batter
battleborn batteries
yeah yeah absolutely yeah i use
battleborn batteries and boho
these guys went on shark tank and they
make fans out of in phoenix and uh
and they're really cool and uh yeah it's
i mean it's amazing man
i love it i love the battery the whole
battery thing is like
you want to talk about like what is kind
of
new and exciting about about the van for
me it's like
it's like what you're doing like the
fact that we can go anywhere and right
and have power you know remember want to
go film stuff and at the end of the day
you'd have to go to a hotel and charge
your camera batteries and all that stuff
up right it's pretty cool you know what
you know what else i've been doing in
here i've been using this as a
tattoo parlor okay i've become a tattoo
artist as well oh
okay do you have any tattoos i i have no
tattoos
i have no tattoos no i can't i'll never
give somebody their first tattoo man
oh yeah yeah i guess they're giving
someone their first cigarette i won't do
it
i thought about maybe getting one you
know i thought like maybe like
maybe that would but would that maybe
constitute like if i got my first tattoo
at 50 is that sort of like a midlife
crisis
yeah it's better than a harley i think
it's cool that you don't have any
tattoos
and uh yeah you know and then tom i just
i love you as a friend
i i just admire you as an artist
i i clearly just follow in your
footsteps like
like uh what do you call it like uh a
[ __ ]
like i'm sucking your dick for decades i
just
love it
he's like okay thank you and uh you know
and i'm
really grateful that we got to do this
if you ever
if you're ever in the desert and you
think you know today for today's
you know van life podcast i'd like to
zoom somebody in
i'd love to do that oh yeah i know for
sure let's do that for sure
i'd love to go on a mission with you
write some
lyrics [ __ ] stupid pandemic and then
let's go link up and uh do that van life
rap song
rap song yeah you know like just
hitting the road with the bros you got
any lyrics
yeah do you have a toilet in your van
you know i do i do but uh you know
i'm going to like i'm sort of like very
remote a lot of the time
so like i'm out in the middle of the
wilderness so i'm also have like just
pure camping style of uh
bathroom facilities as well like behind
the tree
kind of thing mine is is two-wheel drive
not four-wheel drive and that's my big
my one thing about my van i wish it was
four-wheel drive
yeah i mean i mine's also two-wheel
drive you're better off like it's the
front wheel drive right so yeah that's
pretty good like that's pretty good
um i think you know i i uh
i got stuck once on my first day out my
very first night out i got stuck in the
desert the mojave desert
but i've kind of learned like just sort
of to avoid that soft sand
yeah and um yeah i i think you know
you're better off with front-wheel drive
than with real rear-wheel drive
yeah and and uh you know i think it's i
think it's it's pretty good
the truck's pretty good in the in the in
the dirt roads and stuff you know
yeah well we'll see how it goes and man
i can't wait to link up with you in
person tom i just
love you as a person yeah thanks man i
love you too steve oh thank you man
before we let everybody go they if
they're not already subscribed to your
youtube channel
yeah yeah yeah that's very important
subscribe to my youtube channel
it's uh youtube.com tom green
yeah and there's also a podcast to
subscribe to which is separate even
though there's some overlap
yeah so i'm changing my name on my
podcast again back to it's called the
tom green podcast now
so subscribe to that one right okay
but uh so the tom green podcast you can
subscribe to that anywhere
and uh the youtube channel and then all
the social media and then of course
there's the
tom green on instagram yeah on instagram
it's tony hawk yeah i'm on all the i'm
on all the spots yeah
so yeah i enjoy your tweets too
sometimes like you've got real uh
socially conscious things that when i
think about it i think hmm tom's a good
guy
yeah awesome you know there's so much
social media now i would say that right
now that the youtube channel is the
thing that i'm most passionate about
because i just love like the fact that
we can make
things that are almost cinematic and
highly quality now you know yeah
and uh you know instagram's cool and
uh but i've started you putting less
video on instagram and just sort of more
putting it all on my youtube channel i
kind of find that's
the most exciting thing so i've been
enjoying it and you've got a great
amount of viewership on there dude
with regular posting people are
following you on your van life
adventures and it's a lot of fun to
watch
thanks stevo thank you man well i'm
looking forward to seeing you in person
and we'll go uh have to go do some goofy
[ __ ]
yeah likewise man i say keep growing the
hair dude
yeah yeah i'd say i said keep it keep it
coming
yeah yeah i i'm actually enjoying it i
uh
i feel a little bit less uh a little
more relaxed
you know yeah i think part of it is just
like being out in the desert a lot
and this year has been very strange of
course
for all of us um and and uh i've i've
tried to find a way to kind of
you know cope and adapt with with the
scariness of this year by just um
you know doing what i sort of always
loved which is just getting out into
nature you know
and uh and and and chilling out a little
bit i think i'm gonna i think for me
personally
i don't know about how how you feel but
like for me personally like i feel like
coming out of this thing i feel like
it's going to have changed me a lot as a
person you know i feel like i'm going to
be a little bit more
you know less stressed out now i think i
yes i
i think i was i think i was like taking
things a little too
seriously before this pandemic and now
it's kind of like
you realize oh wait like the entire
world can end
instantly well maybe we should probably
just relax a little bit
i like that i like that i can't say the
same for myself
i'm not i'm no less stressed out if
anything i'm more stressed out because
when the pandemic came i i i found
myself adapting i wasn't just on the
road touring so when i started with the
podcast and i'm doing this and i'm doing
that so now there's like i feel like
more balls in the air and i'm juggling
more activities and i'm like
enjoying it a lot but but if anything
it's increased the pressure that i put
on myself to keep achieving and
and you know being productive and uh
i could stand to take a breath and relax
more like you timing
grow your hair out like that dude yeah
yeah we got to get the dogs together too
i know charlie loves
doggies like you know like
wendy and charlie tom you know they're
they're destined to be very good friends
but
wendy's a much bigger [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm sure you talked to windy like that
hey i love you tom man looking forward
to catching up with you man
all right stevo love you man awesome
congrats on everything and i'll see you
soon okay
for sure all right see you guys later
bye tom
so there you have it folks just a great
guy and a legend of comedy
on top of being a personal hero of mine
and i know
that if you go over to his youtube
channel or his instagram or if you leave
a comment to say
hey man uh i came here from the stevo
podcast
and yeah i enjoyed it like tom really
that would mean a lot to him i know that
so head on over there man and and just
let him know you appreciate him
because i sure do and that's it for me
today
thanks so much guys i love you